[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur nos chaînes
régionales de la tnt et sur tv5 monde
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité de ce journal dans les mois
qui viennent nous allons beaucoup
entendre parler des élections
présidentielles et des candidats a
déclaré d'autres sont déjà sur la ligne
de départ pour tenter de réunir les 500
signatures des mers précieux sésame pour
pouvoir se présenter devant les français
pas mieux une jeune femme inconnue de
nous tous pour l'instant de 29 ans
vosges télévision nous dresse le
portrait dans ce journal dans un instant
dans ce journal également c'est le mois
sans tabac le mois pour arrêter de fumer
il faut savoir que 25% des 18-75 ans
fument quotidiennement un problème qui
concerne particulièrement l'île de
beauté comme vous le verrez dans ce
reportage de nos confrères de la chaîne
via télé pas aisée en corse et puis le
portrait dans ce journal d'un adjoint au
maire d'un député d'un sénateur d'un
ministre d'un président du conseil
régional et départemental ont 60 ans de
vie politique jacques valade a des
histoires à raconter sur la nouvelle
aquitaine et c'est ce qu'il fait devant
nos caméras tout à l'heure
nous resterons en nouvelles aquitaine ça
swingue chez jean didier lange dans ce
journal place à la musique et plus
précisément au jazz nous vous ferons
découvrir six musiciens aussi doué en
imagerie médicale qu'en musique et puis
le 11 décembre vous découvrirez le nom
de celle qui succèdera à amandine petit
miss france 2000 21 en attendant la
chaîne via atv a pu assister aux
préparatifs de miss martinique avant
qu'elle ne quitte son île pour la
capitale à découvrir à la fin de ce
journal
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent nous allons beaucoup entendre
parler des élections présidentielles et
comme je vous le disais dans les titres
il ya également d'autres candidats que
ceux que nous connaissons actuellement
moins connu cela ils ont aussi leur mot
à dire comme exemple dan dan une
scientifique de 29 ans corelli
colombelles et marie danielle rogowicz
de vosges télévision sont allés
rencontrer à saint-dié-des-vosges
regarder
cette jeune déodatienne de 29 ans est
sans doute pour vous une inconnue peut
être plus pour longtemps à bouder
désillus donc lui offre le monde
politique et des lenteurs
administratives françaises handan a
décidé d'aller au delà et de présenter
sa candidature aux élections
présidentielles de 2022 je suis pas
d'accord avec la manière dont ça
fonctionne qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et
de réfléchir à l'ensemble des
problématiques et finalement aboutir à
une ébauche de programme et se dire en
fait on va le peaufiner on va aller on
va le l'étoffé et ça va être le un
programme que je vais présenter aux
élections présidentielles
si douze mille internautes suivent son
profil m.ben bien aussi de tirer 800
exemplaires d'un programme d'une
quarantaine de pages qui développe sa
vision d'un meilleur avenir pour la
france cette thématique ils sont évoqués
quelle tâche maintenant de faire
connaître l'objectif sera bien sûr
d'obtenir le fameux sésame qu'offrent
les 500 signatures en février prochain
quarante deux mille élus sur le
territoire reçoivent actuellement de
nombreuses sollicitations comme celle ci
déjà près d'une trentaine à ce jour sur
la ligne de départ son mari endosse le
costume de directeur de campagne pour
l'aider à obtenir ces fameux parrainages
indispensables pour entrer dans la cour
des grands un travail et non on essaie
de contacter des gens donc construire
l'équipe évidemment on construit en
mouvement qui devrait devenir un parti
on est conscient qu'on doit on a besoin
d'un parti scientifique est doté d'un
master en microbiologie handan dit ne
pas être là près des questions d'ego
mais pour défendre des idées c'est
vraiment la science qu au service de
l'homme et de la nature donc pour des
réponses des choses concrètes par
exemple pour l'agriculture biologique
aujourd'hui on est bloqué un peu dans
les moyens pour faire une agriculture
biologique non sans utiliser derby sied
de produits phytosanitaires pourrait
très bien créer et développer des robots
qui se rechargerait à l'énergie solaire
et qui permettrait de désherber
mécaniquement son ambition est de créer
un revenu universel
simplifier les démarches administratives
instaurer une démocratie participative à
l'échelle du pays ce protégé de
l'immigration illégale handan se dit
inclassable sur l'échiquier politique
ayant fait le choix du bon sens qui
n'existerait pas dans l'offre actuelle
dans l'actualité tout autre sujet
maintenant la grogne des pêcheurs à
port-la-nouvelle dans l'aude à 30 km au
sud de narbonne ils sont contraintes au
chômage technique à cause de la hausse
du prix du gazole et de la baisse du
nombre de jours de pêche imposés par le
plan européen de gestion des ressources
de la méditerranée sur place barry isaac
devient occitanie est allé écouter leurs
revendications
en occitanie les chalutiers ont la tête
sous l'eau à port-la-nouvelle trois
bateaux sur 5 sont à quai depuis
plusieurs mois en cause la hausse du
prix du gasoil et la réduction de
l'effort de pêche une accumulation qui
rend les marins furieux il ya une
flambée de tous et et nous on subit tout
ça et nous on répercute pas comme
beaucoup de deux travailleurs
indépendants les hausses du prix du
carburant ou autre et on ne répercute
pas et ça et ça c'est vraiment
contraignant pour les armements et je
vous dis c'est l'équipage
ça devient un problème social en trois
ans le nombre de jours de pêche
autorisée est passé de 220 à 183 et
devrait encore diminuer l'année
prochaine sachant que chaque marin est
payé à la part c'est à dire plus il
pèche plus il est payé
résultat certains bateaux ont dû mettre
au chômage partiel leurs équipages et
non plus de rentrées d'argent
conséquent ce manque de chiffre
d'affaires
pour moi et pour l'entreprise et pour
les pour les marins donc son bras droit
à la catastrophe qu'on ferme mesurant on
est à la limite de ce qu'on peut faire
dans une école d'aller travailler non
c'est une c'est notre force dans la mer
à contre lequel c'est moi par la mer il
ya pas y'a pas de salaire dans ce port
certains bateaux sont immobilisés
jusqu'en 2022 les marins espère que des
discussions auront bientôt lieu afin de
trouver des solutions concernant la
pêche chalutière en méditerranée voilà
sans transition et si vous profitiez de
ce mois de novembre pour arrêter de
fumer comme je vous le disais en titre
de ce journal c'est le mois sans tabac
un mois pendant lequel de nombreuses
initiatives fleurissent un peu partout
pour aider les fumeurs à en finir avec
cette très très mauvaises habitudes on
s'est rendu en corse avec albane
gingembre et enjeux orsini devient telle
est pas aisé ou le problème semble
beaucoup plus important que partout
ailleurs comme l'expliquent le
tabacologue christian st écoutez le
la corse est une région où l'on fume le
plus tout simplement parce que on a déjà
plus de débitants de tabac pour cent
mille habitants en corse que sur le
continent
deuxièmement on trouve encore ceux des
cigarettes un peu de partout et en plus
donc on a le problème du prix puisque le
prix et 25% moins cher que sur le
continent mais a contrario on a 25
personnes cancer en plus on a une
augmentation des cancers bronchiques sur
en france continentale de 20% encore
sonné à 47%
l'importance du bien-être animal dans
nos vies le 5 novembre dernier un couple
de tarn-et-garonne comparaissait devant
le tribunal correctionnel de montauban
il est accusé d'avoir abandonné
volontairement un cheval de poney 3
chiens trois associations de protection
animale se sont constitués partie civile
dans ce dossier écoutez lisa fernandez
présidente du refuge qui a recueilli les
animaux blessés au micro de clément gaci
de la dépêche du midi nos correspondants
sur place
au mois de février joe dawson appel de
la gendarmerie de grisolles me disant
que l' affaire avait été classée sans
suite et qu'il fallait rendre les
animaux donc là c'était juste impensable
on a fait une pétition on a demandé à ce
que le dossier soit réouvert on a eu
gain de cause et depuis
on a attendu ce procès avec impatience
il nie tout en bloc ils ont eu plein de
versions contradictoires pour se
justifier de ce qui s'était passé et
surtout ce qui était le plus dramatique
c'est que quand on est intervenu chez
eux mêmes face à l'évidence quand on a
sorti la ponette de sous la bâche qui
était infesté d'asticots il trouvait ça
normal
à aucun moment ils trouvaient normal
qu'on l'embarquent pour l'année chez le
vétérinaire
voilà et le jugement a été mis en
délibéré au 10 décembre prochain tout à
fait autre chose le 11 novembre dernier
nous commémorions le 103e anniversaire
de l'armistice mettant fin à la première
guerre mondiale l'occasion de découvrir
ou de redécouvrir la tour de leicester à
type val dans la somme érigée il ya près
de 100 ans en mémoire des soldats
disparus
le gardien des lieux nigelle d'avis a
accepté de jouer les guides povero
montbron de louer aux tv la chaîne de la
voix du nord sur place regardez ce
reportage
du haut de ses 21 mètres elle incarne la
mémoire de la grande guerre la tour de
l'ulster rend hommage aux soldats
irlandais de la 36e division venus
combattre dans la somme quand nigel
davies a eu l'opportunité il y a deux
ans entend devenir le gardien
l'enseignant retraité ne s'est pas fait
prier aux annonceurs de francs c'était
pour moi une évidence d ieu de ma
famille ou de certains amis ont péri ici
ici on rend hommage au défunt tous les
jours et pas seulement à certaines dates
comme le 1er juillet ou le 11 novembre
ici on sait souvient des soldats chaque
jour de la semaine la tour de l'ulster
promis mémorial érigé dans la somme voit
le jour en 1921 au fil des ans couronne
et plaque commémorative viennent orner
les murs de l'édifice dans son musée
nigel a accumulé munitions et objets en
tout genre les derniers souvenirs de la
vie dans les tranchées
on a pas mal d'équipements militaires
ici mais pour moi ces objets du
quotidien ce crayon cette pipe ou même
cette brosse à dents sont chargées
d'émotion et selon moi veulent dire plus
que du matériel militaire le 1er juillet
1916 marque le premier jour de la
bataille de la somme le plus sanglant de
toute l'histoire de l'armée britannique
cinquante huit mille hommes hyper de la
vie ou sont portées disparues la tour de
l'auteur réplique de la ln towers
belfast symbolise aujourd'hui le devoir
de mémoire inébranlable du peuple
britannique pour les britanniques et
surtout les civils en fait ils voyaient
leur solde à partir donc c'est à dire
que sans rester travailler s'entraîner
et partira au combat et au mieux il les
voyait revenir complètement transformé
traumatisé métamorphose et aux pierres
et les voyais pas revenir chaque année
près de 250 mille touristes étrangers
visitent ce théâtre de la grande guerre
majoritairement des britanniques mais en
2020 crise sanitaire oblige la plupart
de ces sites touristiques sont restés
déserts
nous nous rendons maintenant dans ce
journal sur les côtes bretonnes où une
algue peut en cacher une autre en effet
si les algues vertes sont un véritable
fléau difficile à endiguer là bas les
algues rouges elles ont des vertus non
négligeable vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage de karine chevallier pour
tébéo la chaîne du groupe le télégramme
sur place
des tapis d'algues rouges sur les plages
de la presqu'île de rhuys conséquences
de la tempête aurore chaque année plus
de 100 mille tonnes d'algues s'échoue
entre ce littoral et celui de la vendée
c'est pas un problème c'est naturel
aujourd'hui l'algue cd plateau qui
pousse en pleine mer et qui arrivait une
certaine maturité ils se décrochent
naturellement et arrivent par les
courants et
les coûts de tempêtes des algues riche
en minéraux et répandu depuis des
générations sur les parcelles agricoles
du territoire mais si elles sont
ramassées aujourd'hui c'est pour en
extraire les principes actifs un procédé
mis au point par l'entreprise
morbihannaise olmix quand on regarde la
composition de l'algue on va trouver des
sucres qui on va retrouver que dans les
algues on va aussi retrouver des
minéraux et des protéines est ce qu'on a
réussi à faire depuis des dizaines
d'années basse et d'extraire chacun de
ces principes est de trouver un marché
en nutrition animale en nutrition
végétal ses principes actifs sont
immunostimulant cas de stress thermique
ou hydrique une alternative aux
pesticides et fongicides
le but c'est de renforcer la plantes et
les animaux et travailler correctement
sur les méthodes d'élevage et dans ce
cas là on peut réduire voire entièrement
supprimé les fongicides les pesticides
les antibiotiques l'algue rouge est
revalorisé à 100% par l'entreprise et
ses principes actifs sont exportés dans
plus de 100 pays dans le monde pionnière
sur leur exploitation olmix travail à
s'ouvrir de nouveaux marchés porté sur
la cosmétique et l'alimentation
et puis direction dans ce journal
maintenant le château de versailles plus
précisément ces grandes écuries non pas
pour faire du tourisme mais pour
l'inauguration du campus versailles 850
m² consacrés à la formation notamment à
celle des métiers de l'artisanat et du
patrimoine justin brasier de télé 78 a
assisté pour nous à l'événement
paysagisme patrimoine bâti design et
métiers d'art tourisme ou encore
gastronomie voici les domaines qui sont
enseignés au campus versailles
patrimoine et artisanat d'excellence le
pilote du projet vient d'être
officiellement inauguré ce lundi 9
novembre à versailles le pilote c'est la
préface on va dire le préfigurateur de
ce que doit être le campus de ce que
devra être le campus à horizon 2024 2025
puisqu'on est on occupe actuellement en
face du château de versailles la tête de
la grande écurie qui est en face du
château
ces 600 m² de plateau qui sont mises à
disposition par le château de versailles
pour travailler sur la voie
professionnelle à terme en 2025 plus de
6000 m² de plateaux seront dédiés au
campus pour l'heure ici deux diplômes
universitaires ont déjà été mis en place
de la forêt au salon et de la terre à la
table objectif couvrir une multitude de
métiers pour affirmer un projet en
traitant de la sylviculture de l'aspect
arboricole du design d'objet de
l'ébénisterie de menuiserie la charpente
donc on voit un maximum de choses dans
cette chaîne de valeur qu'il y ait au
bois pour qu'on puisse pour un étudiant
se positionner sur un projet qui va ne
se passera le campus vise également
l'hôtel à projets une partie qui
consiste à répondre à des demandes de
professionnels du château de versailles
ou encore d'enseignants c'est le cas de
ces tables modulable inspiré des jardins
de versailles pour des salles de réunion
ça nous permet donc pour un lieu de
prestige qui à versailles de mettre en
avant aussi notre travail de montrer ce
dont on est capable ce dont les élèves
accompagnés des enseignants sont
capables de réaliser et ça nous permet
aussi d'avoir une expérience avec d en
dire des vrais clients la grande rentrée
a lieu le 13 octobre pour cette première
année le campus regroupe une
cinquantaine d'étudiants voilà une paix
dans ce journal nous vous présentons
souvent des livres écrits par des
personnalités issues des territoires
jacques valable a écrit itinérance
inattendue aux éditions le bord de l'eau
nous rendons à bordeaux où l'homme
politique il raconte 60 ans de vie
politique entre la mairie l'assemblée
senna lui le professeur de chimie qui ne
se prédestinait pourtant pas à tutoyer
le pouvoir il se confie au micro de
christophe rigaud surpasse
à 91 ans jacques valade fait le bilan
d'une carrière politique bien remplie
dans son ouvrage itinérance inattendue
cet ancien professeur de chimie revient
sur son parcours adjoint de jacques
chaban-delmas à bordeaux ministre
président du département de la gironde
et de la région aquitaine toute une
époque où les mandats se cumulaient y
est exclu de pouvoir avoir une vision
rêve et
porteuse al dire si on n'a pas une base
territoriale forte jacques chaban delmas
disais que un homme politique doit
toujours avoir en dehors de ses
activités parisiennes ou nationale un
château fort un donjon et donjons de
chaban
aujourd'hui jacques valade regarde
toujours avec attention l'évolution de
bordeaux et de sa métropole un
territoire marqué par l'industrie
automobile et aéronautique mais qui a su
aussi prendre le virage des nouvelles
technologies la mutation vers tertiaire
qui a été négative par certains côtés
parce qu'on a trop donné l'absence au
tertiaire ennuyant ce que l'industrie
pourrait apporter mais la relève se fait
par balles informatique par rapport aux
nouvelles technologies par rapport à la
télévision par au cinéma il ya une
activité qui n'est pas négligeable mais
si je pense et bien relier les au niveau
des régions jacques valade a terminé sa
carrière public en 2017 comme
ambassadeur thématiques pour la
coopération décentralisée en asie une
passion pour l'extrême orient qu'ils
continuent toujours de cultiver
nous avons une page sportive dans ce
journal maintenant ils s'appellent lui
sm ninja mais ne vous fiez pas à leur
nom en réalité une pratique le baby foot
non pas dans un café mais en compétition
un sport original est rare puisque seuls
deux mille personnes le pratiquent en
france et une vingtaine dans ce club du
mans où s'est rendu enzo maubert pour
ahlem télé sarthe nos correspondants sur
place on regarde
le numéro 3
non vous ne rêvez pas vous êtes bien un
tournoi professionnel de baby foot
chaque semaine les joueurs du club des
ninjas du mans se retrouvent pour
inscrire des buts à coup de poignet mais
attention ici on ne joue pas tout à fait
comme dans un bar on a des baby foots du
matériel qui est relativement proche de
ce que l'on peut avoir au bar mais c'est
pas exactement la même chose on a des
règles qui sont totalement différentes
et un style de jeu qui est totalement
différent également qui est plus rapide
comparé à ce qu'on peut avoir au bar
avec une balle en liège ici on joue avec
des balles plastique parmi la vingtaine
de pratiquants inscrits au club il y à
lucas 23 ans il a déjà participé à
plusieurs compétitions et vient
s'entraîner chaque jeudi soir dans la
bonne humeur pas question pour autant de
laisser gagner ses adversaires je prends
autant de plaisir quand je joue au
barreau 10 sec au club la différence est
qu'à l'esprit compétition en france
seuls 2010 ans et comme lucas sont
recensés trop peu pour en faire un
véritable sport selon le ministère mais
malgré les apparences jouer au football
de table c'est le nom officiel demande
technicité et endurance physique on
dirait pas mais c'est très complet déjà
le physique parce que ce moment par des
week-ends ces deux jours toujours debout
toujours un marché pour plus de ça c'est
de la stratégie de la mémoire parce que
faut se souvenir de tous les tirs de
l'adversaire tout ce qui t'a fait c'est
beaucoup de points
fondue pas bien sport le club organise
ce samedi 6 novembre un tournoi que le
public peut venir regarder c'est à la
salle la persévérante au mans dans le
quartier gambetta et pour celles et ceux
qui se pose est encore la question
sachez qu au baby-foot la roulette est
bel et bien interdite
nous partons dans ce journal pour la
loire atlantique avec des octogénaires
graffeurs ce n'est pas chose courante et
pourtant télénantes on a rencontré à
rézé ou une association pick up
production propose des ateliers aux
seniors comme vous voyez sur ces images
et pour continuer à leur faire découvrir
la culture de la rue il est prévu qu'ils
signent ici et oui au hip hop après la
bombe a eu le smart et le heat spin
c'est vrai que j'ai plus l'habitude
souvent de faire détonner avec des
jeunes qui s'en viennent vraiment pour
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
assez cool on va dire le graffiti du
street art là du coup c'est vraiment
notre public mais qui est à l' écoute
qui est vraiment l'écouter on demande de
découverte justement
nous repartons pour la nouvelle
aquitaine dans ce journal ils sont
radiologue ingénieur informaticien et
musicien de jazz je vous en parlais dans
les titres de ce journal ce sont les
blue note sextet à un groupe d'amateurs
réunis par jean didier lange l'ancien
président des girondins de bordeaux et
christophe rigaud a rencontré pour le
grand jt des territoires ce groupe
plutôt étonnant à regarder mais surtout
écouter
toutes les semaines c'est un rituel pour
ces passionnés de jazz
ils ont rendez-vous dans les environs de
bordeaux pour partager leur amour de la
musique ils sont ingénieurs
informaticiens radiologues médecins et
ils entretiennent depuis 13 ans une
amitié musicale sous la houlette de jean
didier lange avocat et ancien président
des girondins bordeaux pour qui le jazz
occupe une grande place dans sa vie
l'amérique ça permet de sortir
complètement complètement de soi c'est
la seule chose qui vous tient éveillé la
nuit pour eux pour certains
et c'est la seule chose où on voit pas
passer le temps ou pas donc on peut se
retrouver à 3 heures du matin
très éveillée très excité et on est
toujours envie de jouer quoi donc un
truc qui vous fait sortir de vous même
[Musique]
au sein du groupe blue note sextet on
retrouve des parcours et des niveaux
musicaux différents mais aussi toutes
les influences mais j'ai beaucoup
accroché avec des gens comme quantique
au real comme pat metheny
voilà c'est plus c'est plutôt certain
s'il ya des gens qui kiffent vraiment
dans l'un des faits je suis venu au jazz
par le jazz rock j'ai commencé par
écouter ça car j'étais adolescent et
petit à petit j'ai fait j'ai un peu fait
le chemin inverse c'est à dire que j'ai
remonté le temps j'ai commencé par jouer
les anciennes plus anciennes jusqu'à
jouer récemment je vous un peu de jazz
de la nouvelle orléans et pour le choix
des morceaux la décision est collégiale
personne n'est pas rien
aux professionnels qui n'est pas
satisfait du morceau laisse tomber
comment il simplement il n'y a pas de
discussion tout se passe dans la détente
et la bonne humeur voilà les c'est très
agréable si le groupe est composé de
musiciens amateurs ils viennent pourtant
d'enregistrer récemment leur deuxième
album un aboutissement pour ces amoureux
du jazz jamais j'aurais pu imaginer que
j'aurais pu enregistrer un disque
donc oui c'était lent de fierté
d'attrait d'arrivée enregistrer un
disque puis on a la chance d'avoir
marque qui nous a fait un travail
fantastique jouer ensemble pour partager
et se faire plaisir c'est la principale
motivation de ludovic le dernier arrivé
dans la bande mais cette aventure lui a
surtout permis de progresser là bas
c'est vrai on peuvent être portés on
entend le piano qui va faire ça on
entend un tel qu'ils jouent ça et ça
nous donne des idées ces salles
interactions et donc bas la semaine
d'après on va on va travailler on va
bien on va continuer à progresser de
reproduire les choses et c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça qu'on avance
[Musique]
voilà de la musique et une ambiance bien
sympathique tout à fait autre chose car
ils chassent hall et jean-marc carteron
devient atv ont eu la chance eux de
suivre la toute nouvelle miss martinique
elle s'appelle floria basque où vous
allez la voir se préparer avant de
s'envoler pour paris et peut-être
décrocher le titre de miss france 2022
regardez ce reportage en martinique
à quelques heures du départ vers
l'hexagone c'est une miss martinique
plutôt confiante que nous nous trouvons
chez elles ou la menthe 1 au programme
de cette journée de repos en famille et
aussi préparation des valises
floriane basque on profite pleinement de
ces derniers instants en famille même si
elle est impatiente de poursuivre cette
belle aventure dans ma première semaine
à paris je vais poursuivre ma
préparation avec l'organisation miss
martinique et par la suite je serais
pris en charge par le comité miss france
et nous partirons à la réunion avec les
28 autres candidates j'ai hâte
d'ailleurs d'affirmer en connaissant sa
mère profite de ses derniers instants
avec floriane car contrairement à son
mari elle le sera pour l'instant pas du
voyage après cette élection j'ai donc
avec floriane j'ai eu une discussion
enfin plusieurs discussions pour lui
faire voir que bon la situation sera un
peu plus complexe que celle qu'elle vit
actuellement martinique et lui donner
des conseils
pour qu'elle puisse être quand même
assez avisé par rapport à toutes les
situations qu'elle pourrait
éventuellement rencontrer outre la
puissance de ses parents floriane est
accompagné de son intendante natacha
s'est occupé de tous et rendez vous
depuis son élection et à la proche du
départ elle veille à ce que rien ne
manque dernière ligne droite c'est le
grand départ donc je vise à ce que tout
soit bien préparée qu'elle n'oublie rien
et puis que psychologiquement surtout
elle se sent bien et qu'elles prennent
plaisir à faire ce qu'elle fait
voilà il rendez vous le 11 décembre à
caen pour connaître le nom de celle qui
succèdera à amandine petit l'actuelle
miss france 2000 21 bonne chance à
floriane bien sûr et à toutes les autres
candidates bien entendu voilà c'est la
fin de ce grand jt des territoires merci
de nous avoir suivi sur vos chaînes
régionales de la tnt et sur tv5 monde on
se retrouve bien sûr pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]